yeah I did so there is this [ __ ] guy
sitting right did you hear him yes in
every quiet moment of the movie yeah and
then I didn't hear him breathing though
like every 10 minutes yeah you would do
that at almost every great moment this
[ __ ] guy would just come don't go to
the theater if you're gonna breathe
loudly and cough you will not take the
coughing into consideration when they go
to a theater coughing yeah I'll give
that is like you don't always notice how
you how you breathe because this is
Jerry's ass about being a movie yes so
you know then I sit there and and focus
on blades that are focusing on the film
I'm right right and I'm here
welcome reasons to see where we give you
reasons to see and maybe not to see
Captain America the Winter Soldier
so let's hang out that was my Steve
Rogers impression it's awfully fast and
smiles so we saw Captain America the
Winter Soldier just came back from
watching it on I am a X I'm ex and it
was awesome I really dug the [ __ ] out of
this movie Jerry your thoughts
yeah no it's pretty rad it's definitely
of all the recent Marvel movies I think
it's probably the one I like the best
post Avengers thus far yeah as far as
Avengers phase 2 goes this has so far
been the best one I consider this one of
the best Marvel movies in general every
movie is like different you know Thor
feels like some kind of fantasy epic and
then Ironman had this different tone
going on then this feels like sort of a
spy like an espionage political thriller
yeah and it was really cool scene in
like that I love movies like that and I
thought it was cool to see Captain
America do that it was cool is that a
lot of these movies don't tend to have
crazy intense action like this film but
the action do wasn't distracting the
action was bad [ __ ] ass man I walked
out of this morning to be Captain
America even back to the first Captain
America I was like how are they gonna do
this you know like America is a place
that's you know what were in a recession
and people don't know who to trust you
know America isn't necessarily the
gleaming beacon of you know all that is
good right now you know
trying to get back on track so it's like
how are they gonna do Captain America in
a way that's not pandering and cheesy
and I think they figured out the perfect
way as like shield is corrupt
there are corrupt people inside of
shield so Captain America stands for
you know those American ideals but he's
sort of out on his own you know yeah
what old-school America used to be built
on a bunch of great philosophies but
along the width who are those people
called our founding fathers no no in the
bad guys Oh hydra hydra you do have to
see the first one to understand this one
i liked how they threw in performances
of the actors from the first one into
this i mean you don't get hugh even
again but yet toby jones who has more
lines than this one than he ever did in
the first one they brought him back in
in a cool yeah there's a lot of future
tech in this movie and they don't stop
to catch you up on things so you do kind
of have to acclimate to like oh this is
how you're still here yeah when they
have him as like the part of the
old-school computer thing that was neat
because it's like the technology was
already developed and now it's just an
apple doubt you know they do it but
through old technology which is just an
eClass i would makes sense when you
watch it it's like you can see them
pulling it off because it looks like
beginning stages of those things you
know and the character relationship
between anthony mackie there's like no
transition into this anthony mackie
captain america was awesome like i
really enjoyed you know cuz he wasn't
just the black friend there was no
poking jokes at each other cuz of the
race like they were do they just
understood each other as soldiers man
yeah it was it was me and i love the way
they set them up in the beginning on
your left on your left that was that was
awesome dan because it's like i already
get the relationship with dynamics
cheeky thing to relate over to never
have them have to acknowledge like Oz
because I'm black they're just equals
working together you know they're
they're both instrumental to what's
going on and it's I'm glad to have them
both there I kind of wish Anthony Mackie
had a little more to do but I really
like him generally and I'm glad he got
in on this oh really I was cut I was
happy with how they did Anthony Maggie's
character because it wasn't like Iron
Man 2 you're like okay I guess dodge
needles war machine all this [ __ ]
thing I mean yeah you kind of do forget
like oh yeah Anthony Maggie's in this
movie so what he becomes Falcon I think
it's it's like okay these Falcon scenes
are so good man like you get a bunch of
gun fight so then you also get to see
Captain America
do a bunch of martial arts they got
Arrested Development to come in and dry
which is I appreciate that about Marvel
because they always make interesting
director choices and yes like the Russo
brothers have done a lot of comedies and
a lot of TV who would have never
suspected it was the directors arrested
it oh it doesn't feel at all like these
are the same guys who directed Arrested
Development yeah cuz the film has a much
more serious tone there's humor here and
there but overall it's a very serious
film I love a good like dramatic feeling
movie that just pulls you in it moves
your [ __ ] emotions you know cuz
there's a lot of humor in Iron Man 3
there was actually a pretty good amount
of humor and Thor too a lot of people
instead of as funnier than the first one
yeah there tends to be a lot of humor
even the first one was a little more
lighthearted but this is a sequel so
they're gonna go darker and it was
awesome you know like every great
dynamic I love that every injection of
humor was good too like the relationship
between Black Widow and Captain America
well not even just like the personal
stuff that happens between them but I
liked to what they do was Black Widow in
this movie because some people
complained about having her in an Iron
Man 2 and I understand that in this
movie she's actually essential it's like
oh good I'm glad you're here she's the
perfect supporting character in this
movie yeah much in the same way I
appreciate them not having to
acknowledge Anthony Mackey's blackness
it's accepted that Black Widow is a
woman and nobody makes any digs well I
didn't even think about that
yeah there's not even a scene where some
nameless thug it's like oh what are you
gonna do girly like they don't even feel
the need to do that which is really nice
because it's like she really is just
part of the team and she's so sexy yes
where I want to look up those naked
photos of her again just go see others
again um it feels more real and raw when
you look at the photos or you could just
see under this case yeah but that's
really hard and acting like she was
sending those photos because she was
trying to turn some guy on the visual
effects are great yeah great visuals
throughout man like just the way the
action kind of emotional 'i'm balls you
that more of his time around like okay
the first action scene like was
necessary oh yeah action scenes are
necessary this they don't ever do like a
montage of just captain america kicking
ass it's all individual action scenes
you know they release like a billion
clips out of the first action scene but
it was it was cool there's a fun way to
set it up and then the second ones this
really intense action scene with Nick
Fury getting chased by all these what
appears to be cops
SWAT team and it's like an intense
[ __ ] scene you really hope Nick
Fury's gonna be okay because he
fractures his hand at first it's so good
like they put like a character like Nick
Fury and such like physical damage in
this event where like I think he might
actually die this side yeah no they make
him very vulnerable and that's it's cool
you know it's a nice shift in power and
stuff like that the Captain America ever
uses a gun you know because I liked that
one moment where he has the shield and
all these guys are shooting at him and
that bullets are just deflecting off of
them and killing them yeah like that was
cool they get really creative with a lot
of the action and even though I was kind
of like I don't know where Captain
America learned all these moves I love
the fact that he's like flipping around
and [ __ ] like it was awesome like when
he takes that Matt jet I was like that's
pretty [ __ ] sweet how he's just using
that shield and the shield dude I
thought the way they used it was so cool
it was like an extension of him it was
awesome with like Captain America you
know he's this guy who just stands by
his philosophies and morals I'm like he
says in the movie he's always honest
he's not just like a nice guy who has
powers in this one like he's really
compelling like you can feel kind of the
battle within of what he has to do
because he's like something's [ __ ] up
with shield and I can't quite put my
finger on
and you also there's just that general
essence that he is still sort of an
outsider in the wrong time that was a
great moment where he looks at his
notepad and he has all this list of like
Steve Jobs did it say on Nick Fury's
tombstone yeah the path to the righteous
so it's cool and that was really very
happy yeah man
runner efforts really good but my only
problem with this character was like I'm
suspicious of this guy like from the
very beginning you're like it's a he's
pretty sure he's a bad guy it's not too
hard to see coming although at least in
the in the in the first part of this
movie they did a reasonably good job of
still making me think like hmm I wonder
who is trustworthy and who isn't maybe
this guy maybe Nick Fury was lying about
things maybe this guy is trustful
so even though it's not a far cry that
he should be evil it still made me
wonder for a few minutes I learned two
things about Nick Fury from this movie
one is most of his lines are don't trust
anybody or I can't trust this person
something a lot of the lines of not
trusting something second thing he is
the fastest texter I have ever seen do
you see him when he was writing those
notes to get
in America yeah he was like its bugged
and then they ask a question and then
just flips around like I didn't even see
you type that yeah that's incredible for
one I